[Musica]
tanto tempo fa l'universo e con lui
tutto ciò viene compete tutto ciò che ci
circonda ha avuto origine
potreste averlo sospettato lo chiamiamo
big bang il grande botto anche se in
realtà non fu affatto un botto fu
qualcos'altro
certo non è che abbiamo perfettamente
chiaro di cosa come funziona però
iniziamo a intuire come potrebbero
essere andate le cose
inizialmente indovina e dove na non
c'era niente nulla nulla di nulla era un
mortorio una noia mortale
non c'era la possibilità nemmeno di
ritrovare un baretto aperto nell'arco di
chilometri
cosa che ovviamente non ha senso perché
non c'è una materia ma manco lo spazio
ea dirla tutta non c'era manco il tempo
quindi possiamo dire che c'è stato un
tempo in cui non c'era il tempo non
c'era ieri non c'era oggi non c'era
domani era il paradiso dei procrastinato
ri seriali come me nessuno poteva dire
di essere in anticipo il ritardo era
tutto perfetto ma era un casino darsi
appuntamento
insomma gli ho detto che non c'era
niente ma in realtà ho mentito non è
vero che non c'era niente c'era qualcosa
che però non era un qualcosa e noi siamo
anche un qual quando a questo punto è
che cosa erano queste cose
era un brulichio di roba però non
sappiamo cosa può giusto per capirci noi
adesso qui
chiamiamole kata freme che però non
ditele fisici se non muoiono era un
brulichio di kata freme che però il
problema è che staccata frame che ci
davano fuori dal falso vuoto perché
fisici che meno questo falso vuoto per
questa ragione ci chiamano fuori dal
falso vuoto con la propria gemella
anticata freme cannes e le due ci
chiamano fuori che non già franco rose
si guardavano si non si piacevano si
menavano e si annichilivano sparivano
manco erano nate e già erano morte
morivano tutti vergini a quel tempo e
voi potete capire che era un casino ma
per questo che poté c'erano non c'erano
perché ovviamente questo vi ho appena
detto ma interpretato gli ho detto che
non c'era il tempo quindi chi può dire
cosa avveniva prima e cosa dopo
prima nascevano poi si scontravano poi
si annichilivano o prima se mi kg brano
poi si scontravano poi si è
difficilissimo capirci qualcosa
è un po come cercare di acciuffare una
mosca con tostapane di peggy difficile
ma anche senza senso e sava in questo
falso vuoto un bel giorno avvenne
qualcosa di assoluto improbabile come
disse anche heisenberg non quello della
metanfetamina l'altro heisenberg vabbè
parafrasando disse in pratica che un
evento per quanto molto improbabile
quasi impossibile per noi che potesse
avvenire potrebbe comunque venire a una
probabilità bassissima ma ce l'ha per
poter avvenire quindi immaginatevi lo
stupore in tutte le qatar è che quando
nel falso vuoto di colpo ciccio fuori un
pacco di fazzoletti al profumo di banana
marcata licata freme che lo vedono
dicono è che sta cosa chiesta novità
purtroppo manco lo vedono e già è
sparito condannando tutte le catene che
alcol a naso ma se questo sembra un
evento improbabile
immaginatevi cosa successe quando arrivò
ugo lo vedete hugo è lungo
eccolo ugo era una ca ta freme cache non
aveva senso era impossibile una piccola
piccolissima più piccola di un protone
però conteneva al suo interno tutta
l'energia dell'universo l'universo che
abbiamo conosciuto universo che
conosciamo e che conosceremo era tutta
lì tipo movimento gastrointestinale di
lugo per quanto non abbia senso parlare
di temperatura
possiamo dire giusto per capirci che la
sua temperatura si aggirava attorno a
dice la 33 gradi centigradi
ci sono 33 zeri quel numero che oggi fa
caldo è però faceva un pochino più caldo
quel tempo
insomma un così guarda a sinistra e
vedrete a friend che fanno foto si
guarda a destra fa la stessa cosa e se
ne va un po in paranoia e fu così in
quel breve momento di disagio che
avvenne qualcosa di imprevisto ugo si
espanse
di colpo
beccati che animazione qua la pixar
abbiamo movimentato ugo si espanse e
questo fu il big bang avvenuto circa 14
miliardi di anni fa
perché sì noi effettivamente adesso
siamo dentro hugo hugo è il nostro
universo e per la cronaca sta
continuando a espandersi anche oggi
mentre noi parliamo non ci accorgiamo
però non si sta espandendo e le cose si
fecero molto strane perché di colpo in
un infinitesimale frazione di secondo in
un istante
lui si è espansa dismisura rapide
rapidissimo
dopo di che iniziò a rallentare però poi
si espandeva e più si raffreddava ma
soprattutto in quella prima fiammata
iniziale scaraventò in ogni dove a parte
a creare lo spazio tempo così come noi
lo conosciamo scaraventò in ogni dove
forse elementari come la forza
gravitazionale la forza elettomagnetica
forse nucleare ma anche particelle
elementari o meno trini elettroni of
work o quark come volete chiamarli
chiamare in ogni dove così dove che per
qualche centinaio di migliaio di anni
non avvenne niente di interessante se
non che man mano che lui si espandeva la
temperatura si abbassava es
dell'universo ovviamente di hugo è si
portavano si creavano le condizioni
opportune affinché alcune di queste
particelle elementari si mettessero
insieme
e fu così che alcuni di questi cuork
semmai sono insieme formando neutroni
protoni e ovviamente piero angela
neutroni e protoni poi si misero ancora
insieme formando i primi nuclei atomici
nacquero i primi atomi o e io sono molto
felice della cosa non perché io sono
fatto di atomi e spero che a un certo
punto nell'universo siano nati perché
altrimenti non mi spiegherei come mai
sia qui il problema è che gli unici
atomi che c'erano quel tempo
nell'universo erano soltanto idrogeno
elio è un pochissimo proprio ma proprio
una spruzzata pochissimo di litio quasi
trascurate era scena soltanto idrogeno
ed elio e capite che qui nasce un
problema perché io sono un essere
vivente costruito da molecole organiche
formato principalmente da carbonio
ossigeno e idrogeno azoto lo tengo un
sacco di altri minerali gli altri
elementi indosso un sacco di elementi
diversi solo ispirando le menti diversi
sto guardando in questo momento e quindi
da dove sono arrivati sti atomi se
l'universo non gli aveva creati dove
erano non c'era però un sacco di tempo
l'universo era soltanto pieno di questi
casi principalmente c'era gas idrogeno
ed elio così a un certo punto grazie a
fluttuazioni gravitazionali casuali
questo gas ha iniziato una bella danza
siderale è iniziato ad avvicinarsi e
pian piano che sembrava la forza
gravitazionale di questo gas cresceva
più si formava una palla di gas più
attrae l'altro case più sito questa
palla di gas aumenta ma è più attraverso
gas che quando si è formata una bene la
palla con parta di grass di gara sotto
schiacciato in cui i nuclei atomici
soprattutto nel centro si spingevano si
spintonavano si davano schiaffi coi
piedi e la temperatura ovviamente inizio
a crescere vertiginosamente
ora l'universo era bello fresco ma al
centro di quel corpo gassoso si
raggiunsero le temperature di circa 5 15
milioni di gradi centigradi
già non era caldo come prima ci potevi
aprire un panificio però la facevo
ancora un po più caldo di oggi
insomma a quel punto con quelle
temperature con tutti quei nuclei
atomici tutti schiacciati pressati
vicino e tra i loro iniziati a vedere
qualcosa di molto strano e imprevisto la
fusione dell'idrogeno
la fusione nucleare o se preferite la
combustione dei
gli atomi di idrogeno e iniziamo
attraverso dei processi multi step a
mettersi insieme per formare elio ora
giusto per capirci diciamo che
l'idrogeno pesa 1 e lelio pesa 4 quindi
se tu parli dei processi in cui mai
riuscì a mettere insieme quattro atomi
di idrogeno alla fine hai un atomo di
elio no e c'è un problema
ho mentito lei io non pesa 4 luglio pesa
quasi 4 e capite che non ha senso se io
prendo quattro mele le metto insieme
alla fine ottengo qualcosa e pesa 4 mele
non qualcosa e pesa quasi quattro mesi
dov'è finito quel quasi quella massa che
si è persa qualcuno ma sbucciato le mele
qualcuno ma sbucciato l'idrogeno quando
si è fuso in elio che dove è figlia
quella massa per capire la vita con la
massa tiriamo in ballo alberto lo
conoscete celebra formula è uguale
emmeciquadro l'energia quella massa per
la velocità da lucia quadrato ora la
velocità della luce nera possiamo
approssimare a 300.000 chilometri al
secondo
al quadrato sono circa 90 miliardi al
chilometro quadrato secondo quadro
quindi ci quadro è una quantità enorme m
invece una quantità piccolissimo e
quella buccia design persa quella quella
piccola massa che qualcuno sei fregato
ma se tu moltiplichi un numero enorme
come ci quadro per un numero
piccolissimo come quella massa che s'è
persa
ottenete un numero gigantesco che in
energia
in altre parole ogni volta che si
verificava in questo gigante gassoso
la fusione la combustione dell'idrogeno
si produceva un enorme quantità di
energia nel centro di questo corpo che
si arrampicava fino alla superficie per
poi essere sparata in ogni direzione
sotto forma di radiazione e calore
ebbene sì quella che vi ho raccontato è
stata la prima stella mai nata
nell'universo la primissima e così fu
siano tutt'oggi le stelle attraverso i
fenomeni di combustione dell'idrogeno
l'idrogeno si brucia si forma e io eh si
produce energia e io sono felice che
vada così perché altrimenti le cose
sarebbero problematiche però subentra un
problema il processo è molto simile si
chiama combustione dell'idrogeno perché
effettivamente un po come se buttassimo
della legna dentro
netto no tu botti la legna che in questo
caso di idrogeno si produce energia e in
cambio ottiene un materiale di scarto
che non brucia più il carbone e questo
caso e lelio dopo miliardi e miliardi di
anni che va avanti sta combustione
quando si quasi consumato tutto tutta la
legna tutto l'idrogeno è rimasto
soltanto legno che il nostro carbone
cosa brucia niente quando è quasi finito
dottor idrogeno la stella si spegne il
processo non c'è non produce più energia
e questo problema perché quell energia
servita la stella per spingere lontano
dal centro
quei nuclei che invece volevano
precipitare verso il centro quel che
succede e di conseguenza è che si spegne
questo motore è in un click tornano a
spingere a schiacciarsi verso il centro
e la temperatura torna a salire
vertiginosamente
prima avevo detto che erano 5 15 milioni
di gradi centigradi ecco adesso sono 100
milioni di gradi centigradi tutti con
gli atomi di elio adesso principalmente
che stanno pressando verso il centro
mentre per una serie di equilibri lati
esterni gli strati più esterni della
stella si sono allontanati e quindi di
conseguenza essendosi allontanati verso
dal centro incandescente si sono anche
un po raffreddati diventando rosse
insomma abbiamo ottenuto una gigante
rossa si capisce perfettamente a questo
punto però abbiamo un corpo celeste con
100 milioni di gradi centigradi al suo
centro a quella temperatura enorme possa
iniziato da venire dei processi di
fusione che prima erano inimmaginabili
adesso poi mister a fondersi lello non
l'idrogeno
ed è qui che le cose sono interessanti
facciamoci insieme i conti lei li avevo
detto che pesa quasi 4 se ne mettono
insieme quattro più quattro uguale 8 chi
è che pesa circa 8 nella tavola
periodica di elementi il berillio e però
c'è un problema il berillio e instabile
cosa la terra un tempo di decadenza di
circa 70 tritone si mise conti che
decade non vuoi sapere di esistere e qui
sulla terra diciamocelo francamente al
massimo ci sono le ascelle durante
l'estate
lì c'erano 100 milioni di gradi
centigradi mi sa che non è molto stabile
e li lasciamo stare il berillio
però se prendo tre elio più elio più
elio 4 4 2 4 12
chi è che pesa 12 il carbonio se il
carbonio mi piace io sono fatto di
carbonio forse anche voi non lo so e se
invece vedo 4 4 più 4 più 4 2 4 seggi
chiesa 16 l'ossigeno si maritato mi
piace anche respirare e se invece prendo
3 dl ei due superstiti di idrogeno che
erano stati quindi quattro più quattro
più quattro più uno più uno
14 l'azoto quindi gli atomi gli elementi
fondamentali per formare le molecole
organiche quelle di cui siamo costituiti
tutti noi sono nati nell'universo nelle
stelle qualsiasi cosa sia fatto da
quegli elementi è stato prodotto nelle
stelle
noi siamo stati prodotti nelle stelle
così come qualsiasi altro elemento che
vi circonda è nato in quella stella in
questo modo fino al ferro
il ferro è un infame il ferro è un
parassita di energia non ne vuole sapere
di cedere energia durante questo è
questi processi quando si forma il ferro
è finita la pacchia loro prodotto gli
altri producono l'energia lusi della
tuscia tutta il reattore si ferma e le
cose si fanno alquanto pirotecniche e
che a questo punto la stella sta per
morire e ci sono due modi per andarsene
1 assurdo e l'altro ancora più assosa il
primo è che perde tutto lo stato esterno
di colpo rimanendo soltanto la parte
interna con le incandescente nuda bianca
come la mamma lo aveva fatto insomma
diventa una nana bianca mentre tutti gli
strati esterni vengono sparati nelle
viscere del cosmo formando una nebulosa
ricca di atomi pesanti e questo disegno
venuto bene
e se invece è last questo succede se la
stella non è particolarmente massiccio
ma se invece la stella è particolarmente
massiccia cosa succede
scappate in generale perché quello è il
più grande esplosivo che l'universo
abbia mai conosciuto
nell'arco di un istante a una velocità
mostruosa pari al 25 per cento la
velocità della luce
il centro della stella collassato su se
stesso formando un centro supermassiccio
costituito esclusivamente da neutroni
una stella di neutroni sempre cose vanno
male si forma direttamente un buco nero
vabbè ma in sostanza questo produce
un'onda d'urto talmente devastante da
sparare tutti gli altri non riuscita
mostruoso in ogni direzione con
un'esplosione talmente devastante da
rivaleggiare nella sua breve durata con
intensità di tutte le stelle di ma
galassia è una supernova attraverso
entrambi i modi l'universo si riempie di
polvere di atomi vengono sparati così
seminando l'universo eccola dove
arrivano gli atomi che troviamo qua in
giro è come si fa invece per gli ato in
più pesanti del ferro atomi più rari
come il plutonio l'uranio il torio il
polonio loro che è due volte più denso
del del piombo fretta dove sono riuscite
e per quelli bisogna aspettare gli
eventi ancora più catastrofici ed
estremi ovvero lo scontro tra due stelle
di neutroni è così l'universo si riempie
di polvere e di atomi l'universo
episodio atomi per questa ragione noi
siamo usciti in questo modo questi atomi
che hanno riempito l'universo poi grazie
ad altre fluttuazioni gravitazionali
casuali hanno iniziato a mettersi
insieme quindi gas si sono messi insieme
di nuovo formando dei nuovi e nelle
nuove stelle
la polvere si è messa di nuovo insieme
formando steroidi e perché no dei
pianeti così 4.5 miliardi di anni fa
cerca il nostro pianeta ha visto vincere
un bel po di polvere bellissima ha
iniziato a convergere compattandosi si è
formato questo pianeta e abbiamo avuto
una botta di fortuna incredibile perché
c'erano gli atomi perfetti per quello
che sarebbe successo dopo
miliardi e miliardi di evoluzione in cui
gli atomi proprio quelli che servivano a
noi che erano nati nelle stelle hanno
iniziato a mettersi insieme formando i
primi le prime molecole organiche che
poi si sono messi insieme formando i
primi organismi monocellulari che poi
sono messi insieme forma i primi
organismi pluricellulari per formare me
tu pensa che fatica ha fatto ugo solo
per far nascere lui
l'essere umano prototipo è perfezione
biologica del pianeta cioè non vorrei
dire ma siamo frutto di una fluttuazione
cosmica casuale siamo figli delle stelle
cantava alan sorrenti pensava di aver
scritto una canzone brutta e invece era
un trattato di fisica
[Applauso]